[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right so let's open the doors
everybody
thank you so much to my wonderful
co-host team I greatly appreciate them
as we're getting everything set and
together and making sure everything is
organized doctor did well I didn't know
we were as organized as we really are so
if you want to be organized make sure
that if you are here live with us that
you have the chat open because we have a
lot of information that we are sharing
in the chat including a read type of
what Dr Wallach is recommending for
individuals when we get to the Q a part
of today's program on daily with Doc you
can go ahead and take a screenshot of
that HIPAA re
um restricts us from being able to let
people download and save the chat so if
there's anything that you want to
capture make sure that you either do a
screenshot or use your phone and take a
picture of it
um for the protocol that Dr Wallach has
Recon mending my name is Becca dukes and
as the hostess of daily with Doc I
welcome you to daily with Doc so glad
that so many of you have been able to
find us and you're here live with us in
the zoom room if you are out in the
lands of YouTube or Facebook or Rumble
and you would like to ask Dr Wallach a
question come on over the door is open
you can join us on daily with
doczoom.com make sure that goes into the
URL not just a search but in the URL
daily with
doczoom.com so we did get questions over
here on YouTube some of them that were
able to get to other ones we're going to
do some research and we're going to take
all of your comments and questions and
help us to form
new shows that are actually addressing
the questions that are being asked so we
want to make sure that we're a resource
to everyone and supplying information
that is based on Dr wallach's research
and not just his research but also
taking that research and the formulas
that came from that research
and implementing them
he has done so much around the world
where he has implemented what he talks
about and he continues to do it because
he gets results folks
not only did he do the research not only
did he write a paper
but it's the solutions and the benefits
that people keep continually receiving
from following what he is recommending
I'm one of them and because of the
results that I received
that's why I'm here I would not be doing
this if I did not 100 with certainty
believe in the product believe in Dr
Wallach in his message and believe that
what happened for me can happen for you
or someone you love as well now we're
all different
we're all different and the FDA does
require us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
cure any diseases this program is for
educational information only and is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician
the folks when you give the body what it
needs instead of poisoning in it with
the wrong Foods or chemicals
the body can do some amazing things and
even if it has had that Decline and
damage in some cases
my case
I was able to work through it
and now not have to deal with the things
that I was dealing with even the side
effects so I have to be very careful
with my words I'm looking at my co-hosts
make their you know
I'm I'm looking at their faces so I know
if I'm getting too far off but folks
you know I'm I am so excited because I
am able to bring to you
Dr Wallach who is one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics
and the reason why he's one of the
founding fathers of his the science of
epigenetics is because of his research
it's because of his passion to find out
why in the beginning animals were dying
just all of a sudden
why
animals were becoming extinct in
different areas of the world
and he took that Doctorate of veterinary
medicine he took that Bachelor of
Science and he married it with three
post-doctorates of pathology
to bring a
over a hundred different published
papers
and even more impressive his thesis is a
national treasure in the Smithsonian
Museum
exotic what is it diseases of exotic
animals it's like really thick
and I'm glad that it was not required
reading for this position
I'm very glad of it so thank you Dr
Wallach
but folks it's all that research in
animals mammals
reptiles
um
is it a birds let's just say birds yeah
fish all of those
studies that he did and bringing them
all together
and since we are all created and most of
us have the brain the heart the lungs a
digestive system
there's a lot of things within this
world that link there's a lot of things
that make everything work
in like manner
and when he took the mammal part of it
and all of the research that he had done
in the pathology with the nutrients and
what was missing and when different
diseases were occurring or death from
specific things were occurring what were
the common denominators
and then correlating that into the human
world
and then taking his passion
and going on to be a naturopathic
physician
so that he could
without somebody saying well you're just
a vet why would I listen to you folks
think about it a veterinarian his
patients don't talk to him they've got
to figure it out
and the nice thing about it
is Dr Wallach not only figured it out
but he went on to make sure the
information is
available to all of us and I I love this
um so I like pancakes came in and I'm
sorry I had to have a little fun and say
GF pancakes only but they have written
here in the comment in the chats Dr
Wallach is also a founding father of
modern day nutrition at a much higher
level of understanding than any other
scientist
yes I agree with that absolutely so
forgive me I like pancakes
um
for
for changing your name so I just want to
welcome everybody I see people here from
all around the United States South
Africa my buddy Albert way way down in
South Africa
um and
oh just everywhere Arizona Pennsylvania
California
um Australia Canada
where was that doc Australia New Zealand
yeah we get we get people from all over
the place and I love it Dr Wallach
um even people with my same last name
that I've never met so welcome welcome
welcome and those of you who are out
welcome
um yes thank you sportus
he's talking about wombats Dr Wallach I
think that's your favorite animal right
that's funny well Dr wellick
yesterday we talked about the heart
we all have one
today let's talk about what's causing
our hearts to break
okay well
um the heart of course like all other
tissues requires nutrition requires
oxygen requires blood circulation
and um it's very interesting it has four
chambers it has connective tissue valves
and ligaments and just like your joints
your body that help get the blood going
from these four different areas of the
heart and of course
when the blood comes back from your body
to the heart is carrying all the
nutrients that were digested in your
digestive system and then it goes to the
lungs to get oxygen and then the left
ventricle pumps that oxygenated
blood is full of
vitamins and minerals and proteins and
stuff like that essential fatty acids
out to the rest of the body
um people don't realize that all this
mileage that goes on I think you know
with the normal heart rate for a heart
and beating rate
um at rest you should be somewhere
30 or so 30 to 50 and then working hard
or working out or breaking the lawn or
harvesting corn or something like that
your heartbeat should be around 90.
and we're talking those are beats per
minute those numbers are beats per
minute and per year now just get me if
I'm not correct here Becca I think each
year the average American heart beats
2.3 billion times a year is that correct
2.3 2.8 depends on which which number
you're looking at whether you're looking
at that 60 whether you're looking at
that 90 beats per minute yes
is billion billion with a B per year so
if you if you live to be 50 years old
that's a hundred billion times if you
would be 100 years old it's a thousand
billion times your heart beats it never
stops when you're sleeping it's working
when you're eating it's working when
you're reading it's working when you're
walking it's working you're taking a
shower it's working okay when you're
having sex it's working your heart is
beating constantly
now you think about that
and so it's kind of freaky when you sit
down you think oh my gosh the heart
never stops you don't want your heart to
stop and rest because if it does you're
dead Okay you don't want to do that
that's one of these as Rebecca pointed
out it's Universal amongst
um vertebrates you know we're talking
about mammals and reptiles and
amphibians and fish and birds and stuff
like that they all have hearts okay and
so it's very very important to
understand the needs of the heart the
heart needs all 90 essential nutrients
it's a muscle it requires oxygen
requires these nutrients just like your
liver does just like your leg muscles do
just like your lungs do just like your
brain does your heart requires all this
stuff too
and so if you're missing something
that you might get away with for a while
that your skin requires
uh oh your heart's gonna really not do
well if you're missing those nutrients
okay
and so it's one of those things where uh
I I've dealt with so many
people around the world as Rebecca
points out
we're talking about just excluding the
animals just excluding the animals just
humans I see
in 80 different countries okay including
all 50 states United States and all the
provinces in Canada and Australia New
Zealand the Philippines and so forth
Africa continent South America
Australia New Zealand
I literally see
through the written word and through
what we're doing now okay through zooms
and so forth I used to do it I'd be on
the road 300 days out of the Year going
from place to place to place to place to
place but the zoom thing has really
expanded that and so I'm really
communicating with thousands of people
an hour
per day okay even when I'm sleeping at
night my night it's their daytime and so
they're getting the zooms that has been
recorded and so forth and The Beat Goes
On okay so this is something
um that we we continuously learn and of
course I've dealt with so many wonderful
stories of famous people you know
athletes and politicians and and um
researchers and so forth
both males and females all ages and um
if I may I'll name a few can I name a
few uh Becca you can name a few okay let
me name about a half a dozen uh Kelly
Heron most people never hear me talk
about her she was a teenager uh when I
met her she came to one of our meetings
in in Tennessee and she she was a
basketball player you know six foot tall
girl and she's a basketball player
University of Tennessee and her right
shoulder was just
honestly process aristoritis she
couldn't even live to the basketball so
we got her on the healthy Bone and Joint
pack which we had started for Theo
Ratliff and in two months time she came
back and she became an All-American
basketball player in the women's league
okay is so very proud of her then
um let's see here Pastor Mike Freeman uh
this guy was 30 something years old he
was in a coma for six weeks in a
hospital they gave him only hours or
maximum Days to Live
and he didn't have a G-tube he didn't
have an IV on him they just took all the
equipment off of him and said he's gone
her and so he had one of our great
Distributors up there
uh in Baltimore Maryland who is in his
church Linda Tyler and his wife rub our
plant minerals this is liquid plant
minerals on him and three days time he
wakes up
he shaves okay he
and he goes to his Church's TV and radio
Studios he tells his story about waking
up from the coma
over and over and over and over for 12
hours unfortunately he recorded we made
a wonderful tool out of it telling his
story about just rubbing the minerals on
his skin which he absorbed almost like
intravenously okay and so um we were
able to rub those minerals on him so we
have the tool in the form of a a CD and
a DVD it's called Praise the Lord and
passinati I love that one and then of
course uh let's see here Danny Glover
great movie star okay he was born with
um let's see here epilepsy
seizures all kind of stuff and we got
him on the same program that we had for
Theo Ratliff and within weeks he was
getting better within months he was
cured
and he wrote the last chapter in my
newest book The Wallach Revolution okay
Danny Glover very proud of that and then
let's see here
um Pat Boone great singer and movie star
okay he had arthritis disabling and he
was just not able to work anymore and we
gave him the the program for theoretlif
and he came back in weeks and months and
and he's out there he's in his 80s now
he's just going crazy hard working and
um he had a new movie come out just sort
of towards the end of last year okay
which I haven't seen yet but I'm going
to here before
and we get to the summertime
and uh so any rates he wrote the forward
for the book The Walk Revolution Pat
Boone two great guys and then Theo
Ratliff great basketball player uh you
know seven foot tall uh Becca's got some
pictures of he and I standing together
it's really hilarious here's this guy
seven foot two and I'm
what I'm five foot four or something
like that
it's a great picture Okay anyway we got
him going and uh he made over 100
million dollars when his career is over
all the doctors said his career is over
there's nothing to do for him and they
took his contracts away from the
basketball teams and all that kind of
stuff well he got all that back and he
was one of the most consistent and then
shot blockers and also uh for scores and
then we have um Evander Holyfield great
heavyweight boxer launched his
Heavyweight Championship because he had
a heart attack in the break between the
11th and 12th round it was a defensive
championship against Mike Michael Moore
we got him on the program rebuilt him he
came back and about nine months later
and really really beat up Mike Tyson
who's one of the toughest heavyweight
boxers ever beat it Mike Tyson got his
championship back and who comes back
from an ear death heart attack and beats
a Mike Tyson in a heavyweight
championship fight only the people who
are on the 90s such nutrients what
he had a heart attack what causes heart
attacks because we're talking about what
causes your heart to break and that's
what I'm talking about folks we're
talking about
he had a heart attack because
um for whatever reason he he wasn't
taking all the nutrition he was supposed
to so his muscles weren't his heart
muscles weren't getting what they needed
he had some blockages in his arteries
okay he had blood clots all that was
going on at the same time and so that's
why he had a heart attack and they were
all nutritional deficiency problems you
know just eating a steak every day isn't
it doesn't give you all the nutrition he
wasn't taking everything he needed well
he what he was after he had a heart
attack we got him going he came back and
he won I mean he beat Mike Tyson and he
he's
um what should I say he still goes to
boxing matches all over the world but
he's he boxed for I don't know another
10 years after he had the heart attack
really great guy the last one I want to
talk about is Jerry Lewis and Jerry's
kids from most history supposed to be a
gently transmitted disease it's very
simple nutritional efficiencies and
um
we proved to Jerry Lewis uh we were
working with a
um Navy SEAL uh in many states the
United States and also in Europe we're
curing these kids with most of your
history and Jerry agreed and we had all
these doctors test them again and biopsy
you know they didn't have much history
anymore
and so Jerry went to the meeting of the
mususi association in September of 2011
then was September 4th and they fired
him put a gag order on him so he
couldn't say anything because they
didn't want to hear that we had found
the Cure What
they didn't want to hear that we had
found the Cure All right and so
um
which I say they took his his um
well he just fired him and then the next
day they shut down the Telethon they
ended the Telethon
and they had raised 2.6 billion dollars
for the most history Association to do
the research to find the Cure which we
did
you don't hear about mushrooms anymore
you don't hear about sediment death
syndrome anymore
yeah
and none of their dollars went towards
your research that's correct which found
the Cure
that's correct
and that story right in itself we had to
sell our Farms to get the money to pay
for the research and Sue the FDA to get
these nutrients put into baby farmers
yeah that's just heartbreaking because
you you trust in an association like
that that they truly are doing
what they are collecting the money for
and then to find out
that you and Marvin
took that information
that actually did help kids
and find the causing cure
of what they were collecting money for
yeah
so I have a really hard time Dr Wallach
um myself personally donating to Big
organizations like that where especially
their their CEOs
and their VPS and their presidents and
all of them are making millions I just I
have a hard time with that
so why not take that money folks and
invest it in your own health in your own
communities
and make a difference truly make a
difference in a positive way
so Dr Wallach you mentioned the heart is
a muscle yes
what does it take to support muscle
well it takes a 90 essential nutrients
60 minutes and what are they 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 measures Three fatty
acids and then of course
um we we learned that sometimes when
you're doing extra hard work like your
heart does it needs more so we came out
with the healthy brand of heart pack
which has 215 nutrients the core which
is still the 90 okay so at the very
least your heart needs a 90. but I like
to give it more you know it's kind of
like
you give it that plus because you want
it to work you know I want to take just
two or three minutes if I may and talk
about one of the longest lived people
here Gene Calment from France okay let
me just spend a little bit of time on
her because she talks about her heart
okay
um Miriam Gene Louise Calment
who has the longest confirmed human
lifespan 122 years 164 days okay
um you can see here
the her fate was was approved
by by the way she lived her life she was
born in in Arles France near a Delta of
their big river okay
and and so back in those days 1875
when she was born they're still putting
wood ashes which are minerals into their
Gardens and into their food and so forth
okay
and the Eiffel Tower was built when she
was 14. it was at this time she met
Vincent van Gogh and she said I'm
quoting her now she was dirty
badly dressed and
um let's see here disagreeable
okay when she was 85 she took fencing
you know sword fighting and still rode
her bike to and from the classes
when she reached 100 she's still riding
her bike at 114 she starred in a film
that talked about her life
okay at age 115 she had hip surgery
which I'm real sorry about and at age
117 she gave up smoking which I'm glad
about and she started smoking at the age
of 21 at 1896.
she didn't give it up for health reasons
she just didn't like to ask people to
line up her cigarette for her because
they made funny faces okay just lastly
um
let's see here
okay I'm going to jump to the next page
here and give some of her rules of Life
her rules of life because this has to do
with her heart okay here are the rules
of life for Genie Calment who died at
122 years 164 days she loved red wine
great antioxidant even Jesus drank red
wine even Moses Frank red wine every day
okay
and she says all babies are beautiful
and she said people always ask me what
I'm going to die from and I think I'm
going to die from laughter
okay
let's see here I have only one wrinkle
and she says I'm sitting on it every day
I never wear mascara
if you see can't change something don't
worry about it move on always keep your
smile
and as she says I I think that explains
my long life as I'm smiling all the time
um
let's see here
I have legs of iron okay I'll tell you I
have legs of iron but to tell you the
truth they're starting to get weak and
rust okay I'm just so glad she says um
I'll give you her last statement she
said Being Young is a state of mind and
it doesn't depend on one's body
um actually still a young girl in my
mind it's just that I haven't looked
that way for the last 70 years okay all
right
she was getting these wood ashes I got
wood ashes in in my garden I got wood
Ashes In My Soup I got wood ashes in my
stew I got wood ashes and my
um when they say
um tomato soup tomato juice and stuff
like that we're getting wood ashes when
I was a kid because I was a very sick
boy and I was not going to make it okay
the doctors told my family I was not
going to make it but doing what we did
correctly
you got rid of all my health problems
and here I am now in three weeks time
I'll be 84. I'm just very excited about
that and that's just the beginning
sorry doc
it's five weeks
oh five weeks okay
I'm gonna make you wait a couple more
weeks okay and then we'll celebrate
[Laughter]
okay
okay all right
well thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and folks you know our heart is
so very important without our heart the
blood would not pop through the body
and it's bringing oxygen it's bringing
food and nutrients to every cell in your
body
so if the nutrients are not going in Dr
Wallach
what is the blood pumping through the
body
well bad stuff
okay if you're eating bad stuff it's
pumping bad stuff to itself and the rest
of the body because it's pumping not
only to the body but it's pumping to
itself all the nutrition that's coming
or all the stuff that's coming from your
digestive system absorption is coming
into the heart the heart skims off of
what it wants okay and sends the rest
out to the body
okay now if it's only bad stuff you're
getting
the heart's helpless there
okay so when somebody has they've been
told that they have calcification
within their heart
what bad stuff would have caused that
okay well those are just a lack of not
having enough of the good stuff it's a
combination of both
okay calcification is caused by
inflammation of valves of the heart and
tendons of the heart the muscles of the
heart and it's kind of like you know
when you're playing football and you get
a bruise oh yeah I got calcification my
thigh muscles well the same thing
happens with the heart okay
and um if you're not getting good stuff
coming in to the heart the 90 cents in
nutrients
bad things happen to the hearts just
like it happens to your hips your legs
your back and your shoulders your neck
and your jaw muscles and your calves
your toes your fingers because again
um it's very interesting when you think
about it the heart valves okay which
close the valves so when my heart
contracts the blood goes this Direction
when they open up in a contracts the
blood goes that direction and the Heart
knows all this stuff is kind of
interesting that the heart knows all
this stuff and it's got these
um connective tissue tendons and
ligaments and it's got the valves which
are made out of the same thing these
tendons and connective tone ligaments so
when you're taking the collagen peptides
for your knees and your hips and your
vertebrae guess what you're also taking
it for very very serious structures in
your heart
so this is why the people who
which I say back in the old days lived
on wood ashes
and even even the slaves lived longer
than the than the plantation owners the
plantation owners who died in their 40s
and 50s because all they ate was steaks
for breakfast and dinner and lunch okay
because they wanted to be like the rich
Europeans
whereas the slaves they were getting the
the
um part the lungs the liver where all
the trace minerals were stored in the
liver
and the slaves were living to be 70 80
90 100 Uncle Tom Uncle Remus they're
living the 110 120 and the plantation
owners are dying their 40s 50s and 60s
because all they're eating is meat they
weren't getting any of the nutrients
which which brings me to the keto diet
Dr Wallach because it's high in fats
moderate proteins and low carbohydrates
now it has been proven time and time
when done right
to be the perfect diet
and especially for those that are
dealing with blood sugar issues or with
overweight I was overweight
and whenever I was working on my
migraines
it just so happened I lost weight and I
was no longer anemic
and I was just working on my migraines
Dr well like my body my body pain
so I think it's pretty cool how
everything within the body is connected
and when you give nutrition here
it just
electrifies the whole entire body and
lets the body just start to live again
well and again it depends on where the
plants were grown because plants don't
make minerals if there's they only need
three minerals plants do and so that's
all there's there that's all you're
going to get you're gonna be missing 57.
okay so if somebody could eat the same
diet you're eating and they'll die in
their 30s from a heart attack
even though they're eating the exact
same diet you're eating because they're
eating food that grows someplace else
you understand what I'm saying so you
have to be careful what you say there
because the keto diet is good because
that's going to help you lose weight but
you still need the 90 essential
nutrients to guarantee do you put dirt
from Texas in your car and hope that
there's oil in there no no no I don't
that's the done right part Dr Wallach
when keto done right and done right is
when you're adding in the 90 essential
nutrients ah there you go
see there you go
people have to hear that piece they also
have to take the 90 essential nutrients
along with the keto diet you just can't
eat the keto diet well she said just eat
the keto diet that's why I die why am I
here God
no the keto diet is actually pretty
lousy when it comes to nutrition
I mean it's really lousy especially if
you're doing dirty keto so there's a
difference between clean keto dirty keto
one is going to destroy the heart the
other one's going to help build the
heart so
let's build the heart Dr Wallach let's
make sure that we are doing the keto 90
version of the keto diet there you go
yes you can get more information about
that folks just go to daily withdoc.com
use that contact us I am putting up a
and actually you're gonna find an
article on our website about the keto
diet the pharmacists been put together
and I'm going to be putting more
information about how you can do the
keto 90 and implement it into your own
life
two
one give the body what it needs and two
cut out all the things it doesn't need
so that the body can utilize what it
does need in the most effective manner
well said it's pretty simple
it's really simple
um and I'm doing it from my own
experience and the experience of many of
those that I have been able to surround
myself as a certified holistic health
coach has an associate proud associate
with youngevity Dr Wallach the company
that you founded that is now ran by your
amazing eldest son and his wife Michelle
and just so honored Dr Wallach that
we'll be we're able to have a hundred
percent certainty in you in the products
and in the company
yeah it's a win-win-win of course we're
working on a project right now that's
going to bring 70 more countries to us
okay so I'm very excited about that and
I don't know if it's going to take three
weeks or three months but we're working
on it and uh it's kind of a done deal
but you have to put all the pieces in
place to deal with 70 countries at the
same time
yeah there's a lot of creative shipping
options that have to go into place for
that one doctor well like which folks if
you are listening to this program and
you're in another country or you know
people in another country don't let that
stop you from sharing this information
with them
don't let that stop you them you because
they need it as well and if you have
somebody if you want to share it with
and you have not worked with anybody
within the youngevity company you have
not purchased products you have not
spoken to anybody feel free to go to the
website daily withdoc.com we are here
for those that are not currently working
with somebody if you are currently
working with somebody that's fantastic
that means our message is being
spread and received
we're here for everybody
but get back with the person that you've
been working with and let them know how
you're doing stay in contact with them
and as new products are coming out or if
you still have something that you're
working on that person that you've been
working with can help make
recommendations to help tweak what
you're doing for so that you can also
find Optimal Health
Dr Wallach we kind of took a long
introduction here we've got several
hands up we've got several questions so
let's go ahead and go to the first hand
that is up and hopefully she can unmute
today she was on with us yesterday if
you're here live with us and you would
like to ask Dr Wallach a question go to
that Zoom menu click reactions and raise
hand that is how you raise your hand
when you are in a zoom meeting and then
I see them in the order that they were
raised unless you're the host
who is always at the top
so we are going to go to the first down
that I did see raised and that is Miss
Lewis Miss Lewis go ahead and unmute
your beautiful self please
uh oh
where did she go
is she still there
okay because I asked to unmute and then
she disappeared okay there you go
you can hear me now yes yes ma'am
okay I have a friend who has ITP which
is idiopathic immune thrown by I can't
pronounce it and she has been told that
she can't take vitamins
they destroyed her immune system by
giving her
um president
Predator Jones prednisone yeah
and of course she's afraid to take
vitamins now
her doctor told her not to take them
okay the first thing she needs to do is
find another doctor yeah right right
okay because it's like a doctor saying
no more oxygen for you no more oxygen
for you oxygen is bad for you're going
to rust like iron okay yeah you wouldn't
listen to a doctor who says stupid stuff
like that so if a doctor says don't take
any vitamins and minerals find a
different doctor okay and of course you
can look at our stuff also
um and then you said she has idiopathic
what I didn't get what the disease was
well it's idiopathic immune and it's
from both both see topenia
thrombocytopenia yeah are you familiar
with that yeah that's blood clots okay
his blood clots in the blood vessels
okay okay so do you know how much she
weighs
um I don't I don't really know she's
just kind of average height and weight
and in her 60s okay let's just say per
100 pounds of body weight okay let's go
per 100 pounds by the way no she needs
to get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats which I'm a
bacon ham bologna salami pastrami
pepperoni jerky corned beef spam odds
got to go hot dogs all got to go
I've just wondered what I can say to her
to help her I'm telling you what to say
okay
you can't just take take vitamins you
can't just take Vitamin C this is a
bigger project than that
okay so you gotta give her all the bad
stuff yeah everybody says well just make
it easy tell me which vitamin to take no
it doesn't work that way well she's been
told not to take vitamins okay
women this is the fifth time we've said
that we don't need to say it over and
over and over and over and over you're
wasting your time and my time
okay so she needs to change doctors
okay now she needs to give her all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
meat some oils or gluten so we burn rare
oats no buckwheat no sugar no carbon in
a drinks even the diet one's got to go
and also carbonated water because they
neutralize stomach acid so you cannot
um digest food or absorb minerals
without stomach acid then let's say per
100 pounds of body weight I wanted to
have one uh healthy brand heart packed a
month to follow us everything or a day
so it'll be a half a dose of breakfast
half of those at dinner time she weighs
150 pounds and she needs two health
degree in heartbeats and full dose of
breakfast for those at dinner time I
also wanted to take our ultimate daily
classic tablet says three words ultimate
daily classic tablet she needs uh two
bottles a month of those so you can take
three at breakfast three
um at dinner time and they're going to
support and promote healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries in the brain
the heart the kidneys the liver the
muscles every place all over the place
and including the digestive system
they also want to have our what we call
the gallbladder in a bottle it's our
ultimate enzymes because I wanted to
take two or three of those say five or
ten minutes for each meal so she needs
two bottles a month of our ultimate
enzymes and that's going to help or
absorb all the nutrients so all her
organs and things will work properly
and let's see here then to support our
immune system I also wanted to take our
I-26
I want to take the three doses a day
dose of breakfast lunch and dinner I
like the chewables I take three of those
at lunch time I take three of The Jewels
at lunchtime there's soft chewables
they're not crackly
um chewables they taste like vanilla ice
cream little kids love them so nobody
can object to taking them I-26
and it will support the immune system
okay and let's see here Becca did I need
did I leave something out
no you didn't leave anything out Dr
Wallach but I did want to add something
okay so folks the body needs nutrients
to build cells
it's continually going to build cells
so if it's not getting nutrients are the
cells gonna remain the same or get worse
that's what that's what I would present
to her Miss Lewis see the body's neat
the body is made of minerals it needs
nutrients does it make sense to you for
the doctor to say don't take any
nutrients
about that I know it but to convince her
is something else
well the thing is to to show her that
she needs to think for herself
does it make sense to starve your body
from nutrition and expect to get better
it didn't to me
well here's where the books and the CDs
come in if she's a CD listener she has a
CD player or in her car you get her some
of the CDs like Hell's Kitchen if she
doesn't have a CDP player get her the
book Hell's Kitchen it goes from the
transference of wooden coal is fuel
we're putting the wood ashes into our
food and soup you're probably old enough
to remember wood ash is going into the
food and her soup and just stew and
cereal in the morning and all kinds of
stuff because wood ashes were minerals
it didn't burn plants
um or like 95 percent
um minerals and two or three percent
other stuff okay and when you burn the
other stuff the thing that's left is
ashes is the minerals and this is why
um Gene Kelly lives be 122 years 164
days because she is I guarantee us there
by that Delta the river she's getting
the the minerals from the river over
there but she was also getting wood
ashes back
um 200 years ago she's getting wooden
ashes in her food and this is where
people
how many wood ashes are in your house
when you use electricity none
so it's imperatives that you consciously
proactively take these supplements
including all 60 essential minerals to
make sure you're getting what you need
for your body to maintain itself repair
itself perform properly especially the
heart and the brains and your immune
system your kidneys your liver all that
stuff your digestive system lungs I mean
you think about it think how complicated
the human body is all the different
tasks that it does to bring you along
and everything and for a doctor to say
don't take vitamins find a different
doctor
so Ms Lewis you got the message you
figured it out what did you hear that
helped you it's like what what made that
light switch turn on for you
well I was sort of brought up eating
good food
and somebody's at my door so thank you
very much okay thank you so much
all right Dr Wallach let's go ahead and
go to the next town that is up and Ruth
Ellen go ahead and
unmute yourself please
hello hi Dr Wallach okay I have a
question on YouTube and I'm gonna have
to scroll a little bit so
um because it came in several places so
um Renee is asking any thoughts on root
cause of
hypo
hyperhidrosis excessive sweating my
husband's friend apparently has this
condition never heard of it
blood sugar imbalance question mark so
that's a question and then she says we
asked if she had other issues thank you
support us for that
um
she said he's five foot nine 175 pounds
aphid reflux acid reflux I'm sorry
um
and she's not sure about ringing in the
ears or anything like that so that's all
the information we have because
that's his height and weight and he has
acid reflux as well and hyperhidros is
sweating a lot yeah okay and so you have
to appreciate this can be a skin issue
this could be a blood vessel issue okay
um this can be a biochemical issue and
so this guy he's got to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no gluten so
wheat bread oh so sugar no carbon or
drinks even though that one's got to go
and then
I would also have him get a hair
analysis let's see if he's absorbing
okay may not be absorbing nutrition here
very well okay if he's eating gluten
okay no we buy around oats okay no
buckwheat and all that's got to go but
um I would definitely
not get a hair analysis so we find out
whether it's absorbing uh are there any
toxic minerals in there like lead and
mercury and uranium and stuff like that
and then
um I would have this guide 175 pounds
take two healthy branded hard pasture
months Photoshop I think twice a day I
would also have them take the MSM take
three of those at breakfast lunch and
dinner will be two hours a month to
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discipline every bone Expo
himself including the bone marrow then
the needs the
um ultimate daily classic challenges
there's three words ultimate daily
classic tablets to support healthy blood
flow and healthy blood pressure okay and
then because you got the reflux
keep going doc we can't hear it okay but
I could I had to shut it off okay
and I needed to see here the reflux the
ultimate enzymes I take two or three of
those say five or ten minutes for each
meal to help absorb food and and so for
and digest food and so forth and then uh
the the
um rebounder is for shrink go ahead and
get a rebound and 175 pounds they could
have two or three rebounds a day we have
the sticks uh there's 36 in a box we
have the canister it's at 36 servings in
the canister we do have the cans or 12
ounce cans 12 in a case but the cans do
have carbonation in them so I like to
pop the tops on two cans every night put
in the refrigerator I'll drink one with
breakfast I will also have a half of one
at lunch and then the other half of the
second one I will drink in the afternoon
so I'm kind of keeping my energy up for
all the stuff that's going on in the
afternoon okay and so we're covering
digestion we're covering nutrients
um and so forth
and let's see here
um
and we're covering getting away from the
bad foods and get that hair analysis so
we know what's going on with the
digestion absorption and all that kind
of stuff okay
thank you so much you bet you know call
us every couple of weeks
all right thank you rosellen and next
let's go to Rob
Rob go ahead and unmute yourself you're
on live with Dr Wallach
here I am I forgot what my name was for
a second
I didn't thanks Becca hi doc
um yeah I just want to say that just as
long as uh we're talking about doctors
not only find better doctors but we have
to become our own doctors okay and
you've been leading the way for us for
so long thank you very much for that
learning something new every single day
so
um doc anyways
um uh my question is your
recommendations for Lyme disease Tech
season is coming up in Canada but I have
a um a um a person in Texas that is
battling it right now
um so we only have a few moments here
because I got to run here
so
um when you have Lyme's disease there's
two possibilities ones you have
limousines the other one is the doctor
doesn't know what you got and he's
saying you got Lyme disease so he
doesn't say I don't know okay
and so you those are two possibilities
and so they need to get rid of all the
bad foods to maximize absorption no
fried foods no processed meat some oils
no glutens no Wheaton whatever I know so
sugar no carbonated drinks you support
the immune system by taking per 100
pounds of body weight one hell of a
heart attack
um per month for 100 pounds of body
weight and then indeed the MSM uh take
two valves a month there take the three
breakfast lunch at dinner time and they
support and promote manage repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a vertebrate bone
makes bone itself including the bone
marrow which makes white blood cells and
antibodies to defend you okay and then
I also want this guy or person who is
male or female to take
to take
um let's see here two droppers full or
colloidal silver when they wake up in
the morning
two drivers for collateral silver under
the tongue that say fiber Tim is for
breakfast five or ten minutes before
lunch five or ten minutes before dinner
time and again five or ten minutes
before bedtime
and I go through two bottles a month of
our colloidal silver to pull that off
now colloidal silver was used as our
antibiotic twice for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years until
penicillin came along and the doctors
love penicillin but penicillin only
kills
um certain types of bacteria okay it
only kills the gram positive bacteria
like staphylococcus and streptococcus
that's it
Global silver kills all viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast ah what about that
bingo
okay no more Lyme disease
great thank you doc okay keep us
informed
all right thank you so much Rob and Dr
Wallach it is 12 51 so I don't think we
have enough time for one more hand
um but we do have more hands up we have
more questions folks
yes Garden River flower doc needs his
own podcast that is in the making and we
do have this program here for you Monday
through Friday from 12 to 12 50. you
Pacific Time PM you can find Dr Wallach
and all of our programs that we have
done
on Rumble look for critical Health news
on YouTube critical Health news at least
the ones that they haven't removed for
whatever they choose to remove it from
and the same goes with Facebook look for
critical health so send us a message go
to our website
daily withdoc.com and let us know what
is your favorite
platform that you go to when you are
looking for information
we want to know we want to make sure
that we are getting the information out
there where people are looking and if
you don't tell us where you're looking
then we don't know exactly where we
should be
we want to be everywhere but we want to
pick the most important places first and
that's where you are because you are
important
my name is Becca Dukes I am
proud and humbly honored to be the
hostess of this program daily with Doc
and I am even more humbly honored to
have
co-hosts that help me with this program
we have Russell and Sanchez
who's like we're joined at the hip
whatever I can't do she can whatever she
can't do I can and it just is a perfect
pair but we can't do everything and I
love the fact that we're able to call
upon Phyllis Anderson who has been with
youngevity one of the longest standing
Associates within youngevity who has
even more knowledge in her husband I
love you Andy and we have sherry
Browning who has been a health coach
with an and certified health coach
but took our certified holistic health
coach course through the Institute of a
holistic health and learned more about
nutrition than she had in her other
coaching program and now she's taking
both of those and putting them to work
and just excited
with the ability to really really help
people because now she has the solutions
and youngevity folks is a solution that
continues time and time and time again
to provide results and the same with
Maryland pizera sphere she just has a
heart and passion for people
I love it that she is like Dr Wallach a
researcher she loves to go deep and
stuff and
help people
so folks do you have any of these
characteristics do you like to help
people do you like to research do you
like to do computer geeky stuff do you
like to talk in front of people do
videos be goofy be serious
technical skills
need to make an extra income
get back with a person that shared this
program with you there is a place within
the youngevity family for you and that's
exactly what we are we are a family we
are communities helping communities
build a stronger world
until next time
thank you so much for joining us here on
daily with Doc if you are not working
with anybody if you have never
spoken to anybody about youngevity about
Dr Wallach you have not purchased
products from anybody
use
and you were not referred to somebody to
this program to watch it because if you
worry you better get back with them or
else they'll be mad at me
and I don't like my friends mad at me so
please get back with the person that
invited you to watch this program if
there's nobody to think I have a call
team standing by at 855-949-3377
[Music]
or you can go to our website
dailywooddoc.com use that contact us
send us an email I am going through and
getting to emails in the order that
they're received and I have a team that
we're we're going through those with me
because we want to make sure we're
meeting people where they're at and
helping people achieve what they want to
achieve
in life whether it's Health financial
or being part of a community
until next time bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]